and why you won't talk to Kim jong-un
about his prison camps the only thing
we're doing right now as you can see
right now I thought it'd be where's your
plug-in right now and that's what
there's one thing I'm trying to earn
them why won't you actually bring up the
prison camp issue with and his human
rights issues that's not my job that's
not my job and it is in a sense your job
because you're the only American with
access to him well unlike I'm doing
right now and hopefully we do one thing
this game before his birthday it's for
his birthday and hoping that if this
open your doors and we can actually talk
about certain things we could do certain
things but I'm not gonna sit there and
go and say hey I be doing the wrong
thing it's not the right there dude he's
my friend first he's my friend on the
world he's my friend I love him
are you aware of the 200,000 people
locked up in North Korean prison camps
you with a lot of people in America is
locked up like that too
we're not talking about America we're
doing my North Korea which one guess
what it's the same thing in 1984 right
nice ating forward in Russia there's a
charter nucleus in Russia right the guys
who went over it and stopped it Carter
guess what a 1993 who did it it was what
Clinton I'm on the president I'm just a
guide is one of over just up the time
you're a guy you're a guy with
unprecedented access to Kim jong-un he
is your friend for life as you say why
therefore will you not speak to him talk
to him about serious concerns about
human rights when also when the time
come when I do that I'm gonna sit down
talk to all the people on the wall when
I time come i'ma tell you what
everything that happens but right now
and what these guys go ahead and put on
a good show for him for his birthday
we talk about political stuff anything
about the refugee camps yes I would say
there is no refugee camps they're prison
camps people are tortured and then we
have prison camps here in America too